hello YouTube Ian's this is the Reuben
report i'm dave rubin and we're doing
something different we've already
shifted things after only five or six
episodes we're going with two guests
this time because these people are of
such high comic value and moral fiber
might I add and I thought we could only
fit two of them at the table miss Kelly
Carlin mr. Rick Overton how are you guys
doing fine i'm glad i have full of moral
fiber and you're our first repeat guests
might oh I'm so excited do I get do I
get like a t-shirt or something you will
get something at the end okay good okay
I'm in it for the swag to just get us to
put that out there a mug or sticker
anything and we didn't even give you a
mug at the table while you SAT you think
you're gonna leave here with the mug
okay I'll just get a coffee cup and a
marker pen and write the name little bit
report out on it yeah well you'll get
some sun chips on the way out that'll be
eight hours all I'm asking let's get to
it I feel good about today the Pope did
you know we have a new pope in case you
didn't hear about that on every news
channel endlessly for days it turns out
that can you believe that I just got the
other commemorative plate I got for
which all over again yeah oh so the Pope
how many of those plates do you have by
the way oh they're dating back since
like 1300 yeah that's right yeah the
Pope it turns out that our new pope Pope
Francis might actually be down with the
gays and I don't mean on the down low
with the gays which many of them often
are just down with the gays it turns out
that a couple years ago in Argentina he
told an activist and former theologian
at a Catholic College that he's in favor
of gay rights any favors civil unions he
didn't buy into gay marriage which none
was passed in Argentina but is this
progress Kelly oh well I well I mean if
it was true it would be progress it
would be enormous progress it would be
amazing progress uh so you don't buy
this theologian this guy that works at
the Catholic College who says this well
the thing is that it was a private
conversation you know so he was at the
time it was he a cardinal or
whatever it is so he was you know having
a private conversation but I understand
that in Argentina he was publicly very
much against this law yeah so I don't
know but I you know I love the Jesuits I
think if you're gonna do the Catholic
thing you got to go Jesuit they're
they're intelligent they're very well
educated it doesn't surprise me if he
actually had that personal point of view
about you know gay marriage or whatever
it is so uh uh it would be huge it would
be you know what it would be a miracle
it would be a true miracle Rick could
this be could we possibly have a down
with the gays Pope well yes i am a pope
who listens to the people particularly
the ones taking polls right now you know
I I think he's stuck in a pretty tough
position yeah because the other guys
going start the cars that the car the
wrong to me start the car compactor
stuff forget to forget those clothes
street clothes only we're going we're
getting out there's no shoes given the
different passports will pick one on the
drive and just like I get out of Dodge
dash out of there is what that was makes
me wonder what's coming down that's the
wave this next guys got to stand there
and take when it crashed the beach what
could it be what could well the word is
out that the Catholic Church is a clown
car chuckecheese bounce castle full of
closeted gay guys you know it's jammed
like sardines with them and the right
wing of the right away party any place
that they're both safe houses it's like
nine feet of concrete to get to me once
I'm doing all these bad things with the
big cross in front of me there yeah say
yeah so i'd say like the republicans but
a lot of times you could say when it
when he's mowing the lawn way too much
when he's you know he's going up there
mow the lawn and firing an assault rifle
yeah okay he's gay yeah so is it though
is it a house of cards like if one of
these guys especially now this guy's the
Pope I mean even if he was a little more
okay with the gays does the whole thing
just crumble and then it Out's everybody
and
the whole the whole thing just disappear
it all falls apart one can only pray
you're praying there's miracles and
there's a lot going on here I'm trying
to get in the vibe with this you know
this is this is a institution that had
something called the assessing the
assassins which they use to murder their
own basically so which day yes the whole
Opus Dei all of that and and so I I
don't know I mean they're clearly i mean
it's every institution on the planet
that has been around for over 200 years
is being questioned as being undermined
the Foundation's going away it you know
the Vatican's going to go through some
growing pains I have some hope that this
gentleman because of his his ability to
really connect to people I mean this is
a man who really does take the bus I
really do believe all of that about him
his own moral fiber I think this could
be interesting I think he could push
some reform and and I mean you know
let's face it they're never going to be
lefty progressive I mean it's just not
who they are but if they could at least
participate in the 20th century that
would be exciting yeah be nice what do
you think I mean is it is it possible
that he does do this and they come along
a little bit but isn't it just a numbers
game for them like they can't back
something like a marriage because they
need people to procreate so that they
get the numbers at the church so they
make the money in the day clearly he's a
demographic pie wedge of humanity of
choice that they would spun the lazy
susan the mountain hate us done with us
hate us whoa hang on
here the Hispanic community yet he looks
white because he's Argentine okay we'll
take this little piece of cheesecake and
we'll just dump everything doubles down
on playing that last crowd that gets our
jokes yeah you know don't forget bonobos
calm is the official outfitter of the
Ruben report they've got great new slim
fit shirts I've never felt sharper enter
code trr 20 for twenty percent off your
first purchase